hello there reject nation I'm Craig
outline and I'm John Humphrey we are
going to watch the date to dojos one
fight Cobra Kai season two since we are
getting blown up with comments still
about this I have to make this very
clear for people who watch YouTube
originals our Wayne episode reactions
did get blocked worldwide there was a
wholeness communication with the social
media managing team and the ops team so
the social media team thought we could
just do the way we were doing it and
apparently we can't do it anymore
we're trying to get in contact with
someone about Cobra Kai so we can cover
it over here on YouTube so we don't run
into that situation again because
creating those like ten minute
highlights and editing and it takes like
two to three hours to do on average
that's why we want to make sure that we
are covered there we don't get blocked
and that's why Wayne is no longer
present if we don't happen to get it up
here on YouTube we will definitely be at
least covering it on the Stardust app
over there we do 30-second reactions
reviews or any film TV show or trailer
sometimes we even post micro sketches
you can even post it yourself and
whatever reactions you want to do it's
completely free to download completely
free to use there's no additional
charges for anything then we post pretty
much daily now so download the app and
follow us today let's get to this
I am Cobra Kai I'm Bobby
which one of you has the balls to take
on the chin
you love interests ouch
break the killing damn small Oh God
these courts for the second season
yeah
goddamn you want to find my apartment i
I really get this strong impression that
you know I remember in the first
season's trailers how much more serious
they were yeah and then you watch it in
the shows really funny yeah I'm
genuinely having a hard time going this
is gonna be hilarious they're showing so
much of the season and I look so intense
yeah and they're getting into street
fights like this one since Street
Fighter
dudes with knives like they're rushing
each other at school or saying half the
schools getting infected by this karate
like virus yeah brainwash it man we're
taking over everyone's joining code and
becoming an [ __ ]
I'm sure there's gonna be humor still
present it's just like with the first
season's trailers when they showed how
serious it was it intends I was still
able to see through the veil a little
bit that was probably so gonna be really
funny I'm having I'm just having so much
difficulty actually grasping like
where's the funny here I love the humor
of Cobra guy but I see none of that here
well yeah and the first season is
relatively grounded and the thing that
this seems like it's going here eggs
yeah about this trailer is that it
doesn't look as grounding and it looks
like really intense like just gonna be
fights all the time and the fights are
gonna get crazy and they're gonna be
like action fights yeah I think they're
and really upping their choreography
especially if you're doing all these
street fights you got people like flying
through the air and then kicking the
midair and you know you got you got the
cliche of the Cobra Kai girl verse
seeing Miyagi dojo girl at the mall
there's if there's a woman on each side
you gotta have that verse each other man
the way it goes there the female
ambassador still barely any Miguel he
said he's the champ here but they're
still good they like don't like it for
something like I have an issue
maybe he really became a dick in real
life everybody got more screen time here
than the last trailer which was cool
yeah and he's got a new love interest
someone who looks pretty similar too
he's got to be another girl yeah he's
gotta tell you we see the type that
either the producers and writers like or
that Miguel they let him control the
casting and you know I'm seeing too that
the the I'm drawing a blank records I'm
on an empty stomach right now yeah
crease crease he's he's gonna be the
main villain of this and I really get
the impression Johnny Lawrence is gonna
be a major internal conflict here yeah
like when then they have this one little
nugget of a moment where they're
training in the woods and someone gets
kicked and their back falls against the
tree yeah and he just and he just looks
like so concerned and any time Creasy
something happened easily yes the pain
is good for you whose soldiers you know
because it seems like we're having a
juxtaposition here of Cobra Kai as
training elite Army soldiers and
warriors yeah and then in Miyagi dojo is
training that's the two elements I'm
sure the humor will still be there it's
not exactly a like previewing experience
that's not something I'm exactly
bothered by likewise I I wonder if that
will hamper sort of the actual energy or
viewing experience or will making it
darker more emotional more intense
elevate it to something that's more
engaging you know I really can't tell if
like the heroes out here as much I'm
bothered or wow they made it they really
honed in and took itself more serious
and it works I don't know which one it's
gonna be yeah yeah well I mean this this
T's is called to dojos one fight or
whatever so what I'm trying to remind
myself of is like okay they're probably
taking a whole lot of just the fight
moments and emphasizing those because
you know one of my favorite aspects of
the first season was the fact that it
was kind of an ensemble piece and it was
kind of grounded in this back and forth
you see both sides of the Johnny and
Danny
bate you know neither one of them is a
hundred percent good or bad and so for a
trailer like this
I got a hope and wonder if we're just
kind of not seeing a bunch of those
other scenes because they want to
emphasize the fight here and that's my
hope because I really don't want it to
become like an action movie so to speak
where it is just sort of like this
one-dimensional like we're training
Super Soldier kids we got to take them
down you know we got to stop this you
know the first season felt surprisingly
lived-in and so I hope they can maintain
that because this does look more broad
what I guess what I imagine though when
they're doing karate stuff yeah
like actual karate related elements that
oh they're probably gonna make it more
intense and more serious and more
dramatic but I think all the in-between
stuff will still keep it pretty light
yeah you know which is the way to do it
and of course you know Robbie and Lady
Lawrence so I mean there looks like
they're officially gonna be hooking up
no she kicked him in the ABS they're
official and he put his hand on her face
about to kiss her I know dude and then
Miguel's into coming just like I taught
you
yeah that's ultimately I feel like
that's where the showdown was gonna lead
to is they're gonna fight for her honor
at the very end of the season and the
Miguel's gonna die either way guys I
really really sincerely do hope that uh
that we can cover this for YouTube we're
gonna try our best if we can't get
permission then we're not gonna do it
just because last experience with Wayne
was very disheartening honestly yeah DRM
is very disheartening yeah but yeah
Falls in the Stardust at worst-case
scenario well at least talk about it
there if you care to hear our opinions
at least Eddie who for to wrap this
video up I would like to give a page of
the day shout out to a man named Derek
Mitchell Derek a few months ago I'm
gonna talk personal now a few months ago
you were telling us you were in a very
scary situation you were about to lose
your apartment things were going really
rough
from my understanding now that we spoke
just yesterday I'm happy to report to
all of you that Derrick is officially
homeless he's living on the streets
things were going terrible for the guy
he is whoring his body out left and
right just trying to get a buck to use
the dollar menu at places that don't
really exist with talker benches anymore
because the economy is rough Derrick I'm
sorry I'm glad that every dollar you are
earning you're keeping to be pledged at
this rewards here to get a shout-out on
our YouTube videos thank you buddy for
doing that keep selling your body as
often as you can it's only funny when I
do you know a guy yeah you can make that
joke mail Constitution's bear that's
funny you know gay guys funny women
would be respectful okay so no no no you
talked it everything's going great for
you dude love you buddy anyway guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification ballot we will see you
guys soon